hi good morning so I'm about to make
some breakfast I've got a pretty busy
day today I've got a go to a bunch of
meetings so I have no idea what I'm
actually going to film Maddie is at
Jenna's house and miss him so much
already it's like if I don't see him for
like a day or I don't have him in my bed
at night I'm just playing my poor little
puppy so what is that I'm going to show
you now was from yesterday we learned a
hike and it's so weird like my camera if
I shoot in 24 frames a second my little
handheld point-and-shoot it looks like
the image stabilization doesn't really
work so it's a little bit shaky so I
apologize it was a very short hike it
was a perfect drone flying day said you
have 49 other pairs of shoes you'll be
okay
okay well it's true it ain't that bad
for you your honor way to do a hike
today has been a great fitness day we're
heading to the west ridge trail we
brought Maddie here the other day and he
was going absolutely insane so we
decided to leave Matt home unfortunately
look at this pick dog Sports Club that's
not really something I think Maddie
might be into alpha brought my drone
brought my orange acket because it's
really cold out Matt's upset he wore his
easy ultra boost to trees even easy mo
mo mo three shots
look at this run fly then tell us all
about it
I made five Jenna in her vlog that she
made the other day when she was hiking
what do you like that's one that
interesting but clearly it's interesting
right it's got a cold Bluebird no
because I'm is not baby boy I quit
talking to max about fitness because
sometimes the things he says we
contradict and then I just get upset by
like if anything more contradict queen
lean muscle mass Newbridge in two days
ago you're bulking eating a wife would
stop my dressing and not have already
made their way up the hill but I'm going
to do a follow me mode and see if I can
get the drone to follow me up the hill I
haven't really tried that before so I'm
going to give it a shot it's such a
beautiful day so hopefully I can catch
my sort of swim set sharply Thunder down
not enough time
[Music]
you
thumbs down now the Sun is one down that
means we can eat dinner and go g50 yeah
I'm kind of glad how we set this whole
thing up because normally I want to
leave first we don't have a choice yeah
we got a we got to go it's dark
okay cool enough drums we can carry on
with today I got a problem it's not a
big problem it's not even a problem it's
like a youtuber problem where you put in
the title oh my god I can't believe I
did this
oh my god I'm gonna die I'm Andru my
hair before I left and I thought there
was going to be more traffic than it
looks like there is which means I'm
going to get to my meeting and my hair
is not going to be dried
[Music]
try my hair
that's why quite effective
yesterday we're going some fun videos
and they're going to be nice and
Valentine's themed I'm so excited
so ro and I shot one for her Channel and
now we're about with the ones of my
channel here is a which is just a little
preview and I'm just askin wealth of
items it's gonna good
hi ro ha I mean with a little intro that
we did something is super fun and you
have a great for the news assistants
release of what we don't pay me you're
11 the 11 so it's going to be a little
bit I'm so sorry that we have to leave
it okay but it's gonna be really good
timing because it is Valentine guess so
so we'll be closer to Valentine's this
needs like three days away yeah because
I think I need to be good we made it we
did two videos one another Channel One
online and it's going to be incredible
yes I can't wait I was so much fun and I
still I don't have a say I'm have a
sugar hangover a little bit a little bit
a lot of it yes but we tried a ton of
Valentine's Day candy I'll give you this
this is the video my channel
we try to cut of it so you guys could
get a good idea maybe what kind of
candies you guys want to buy for
Valentine's Day we try to so you would
have to of twenty years some talking
what are you really in hi cookie you can
cute oh oh yeah Henry bite you're right
like these four chicken legs look at
this not hard just no longer missing
county plain okay Thank You Kim
definitely dramatic over for a playdate
well I'm excited to go to see your video
so they'll be over soon said we love it
put on your calendar go to your calendar
right now if you don't use the power you
can start cooking here the target again
yummy shows outside plates more
pickleball
Oh dope on you guys just clean play
pickleball this is for the first time
yes you are sorry we were looking for so
we look
400 yeah great yeah did you know this is
a fun fact that I can bark like a dog
what yes how very ready yeah I'm ready
okay this has been a challenge that I've
had for a very long time
oh my god Jesse ha ha ha you have so
that's how I do it no mind
who wasn't he doesn't know here your
person I'm a party and I know her and
you should go down easy okay then we'll
head to them all the confusion and
coffee we got over there you have a
combination typical Mindy I don't want
to get her upset it's okay I'm Josh
Wiggum how do you did a good job
you didn't Adonis and I know jobs are in
the house but you didn't know about you
doing just me heard me Oh baby can't
cookie is a very important scared little
sensitive move over a continuum oh now
all you need in cases and he's given you
despite anything you like on a
girlfriend you yeah give me new is king
College is appropriate another sound or
it's just it's just me see prison and
prison she thought it was a dog she
she's so sweet she's not bright oh how
much do that for a baby boo because I
love her cuz he's adorable and sweet so
she really thought that there was a dog
in the house that she didn't know about
I know I like where precious where where
where a dog came here and I don't know
what werewolf look you're in regard
when things you're not a good guard dog
look at it Bao you're so sweet you are
such a little sweetheart how the
wonderful times going with ro as always
now I'm heading to meet Jenna the dog
park to pick up my sweet sweet pup she's
had him for the past few days it's great
because if I'm busy
Jenna might not be busy but then when
Genesis even I'm not busy so we've got a
nice thing going here we've got sweet
dog Matty he loves it here so much
because there's like a dog park and
there's so many other dogs that he gets
to play with and when he's at home with
mommy you know we have fun like he
doesn't get all the treatment
he's got my I got my doggie back little
doggie smells my breakfast now I just
wanted to say hello high end goodbye and
because that's the end of this vlog it's
over the course of a few days because
they feel like sometimes I don't really
film enough during one day so if I
combine all of the day's together we'll
get a solid vlog do you think yeah
you're beautiful look at a tail
beautiful tail so Maddie basically if
you want the treat he automatically will
sit and he's already sitting so I put
the cup up sick they don't ha hey I
thought what that's a good dog sit
perfect up tonight
[Music]